Chris and Krystal we are here you are
married and the wedding is finally
airing on TV how does that feel you have
to have some built-up excitement people
to see it yeah I would say we definitely
have that anticipation we've been
waiting and it's been interesting
because we were married two months ago
right and so we can't really like show
photos we haven't even seen photos until
just a few days ago we couldn't show off
our wedding rings and couldn't really
talk too much about it so now it's
finally like scream it from the rooftop
and like delete it
yeah like washing tomorrow with everyone
will allow me to wake up on Wednesday
mica huh okay remains it hasn't truly
sunken in yet no I think every day it
feels like a fairy tale like it just
feels like something always makes me
wake up a say damn like this is so crazy
like damn that's why I said I'm like I'm
always like I can't believe I married a
supermodel
I'm like all right but I mean Barbie
incarnate there's nothing wrong with
waking up and going to bed seeing that
so by the way can we show off the Rings
can you guys hold them both up and we'll
get a little shot Rigo if we can I mean
the wedding rings are here you went for
a rock for a rock you know the thing was
this she was like I'm gonna add more you
know diamonds to my reign and get go big
I go well you're getting more rocks I'm
gonna get a fat rocks oh don't you got a
hammer a hammer with the raw diamond
yeah very cool every different yours
really fits into each other here yeah I
really wanted um I was looking at all
these fans and your Neil was kneeling
was there when we were picking them out
and I was like honestly like my dream
ring is is to conform to make my
pear-shaped diamond I don't want the gap
in there I just want it to almost be a
crown to support you know the ring he
gave me that money Chris asked me to
marry him yeah and so for me it just
feels symbolic of our relationship like
the wedding our marriage is the
foundation of when we first met we're
gonna be going forward so it's really
symbolic to have this little you know
crown element the first time you're
hearing that yeah that before but I like
I like the imagery I was like man okay I
like that
you thought you just wanted a rock like
you wanted to up the bling factor I
wanted to be different um Neal showed me
all these rings and ever that's just the
classic band and to me like I'm not
quite like I just don't like the the
norm I like to go unique I like
different yeah and so this he was like
well if you want different this is what
I got and I sorta kind of do your thing
and you know he showed me an example and
he handcrafted it yeah I was like wow it
came out I mean they were so so that's
kind of a custom yeah okay I was just
seeing him honestly Neal like just
talking to the great guy like we've only
seen him say like 10 words yeah in all
the seasons like we've seen him on TV
I'm very sure but he has such a great
personality and he made the process of
us getting bands really special and I'd
say we went straight from me doing
dresses to going to kneeling jewelry and
it was he just he made it really sink
and then this is web and support and
yeah that's really excited for the
wedding so you guys are finally going to
be able to share folder we haven't seen
honestly so much that uh that was shot
and then there was just so many iconic
moments that I'm really grateful for
everyone to see you but also for our
family just to have his memories and
it's like it's crazy because not too
many people could say they did this yeah
I could tell about sweating but to get
it on a stage where you actually got
what you wanted with how it looked and
how it felt and there was a it was it
was incredible and honestly I'm excited
to watch it back
how will you watch the episode like a
bottle of champagne together with
friends family what are you doing man
well we're gonna be here because we're
gonna here in LA we're gonna be here
nowhere I think we're good together were
some close friends of ours and just
watch it and play it back and have some
fun so you guys are seeing the episode
you know I mean that's got to be
emotional to watch it back did you cry
dad oh yeah he goes oh yeah it's like I
was crying but then I was so happy at
the same time and I'm like man I've
never felt all of these emotions before
like I was like man is this is what
women feel like on their period because
it's like I'm so happy and sad and like
I want to I want to cry
and like I was very hormonal I felt like
and so she's just like hit me as soon as
it open you're all good down very open
an emotional roller coaster as she
walked up to me but as soon as I grabbed
her hand to pull her up on the altar all
those feelings dissipated and the focus
was on her well crystal now you better
expect him to be empathetic with you for
the rest of you I'm gonna so you see her
for the first time the day of you're in
tears that flower wall you guys was that
your favorite part aesthetically I mean
we've seen glimpses of it but it had all
these flowers it had crystals for
crystal it looks gorgeous the crystal
chandelier was probably my favorite like
all the crystal chandeliers yeah I don't
know if I could just pull one Dame it
was my favorite I think just how it was
completely encompass all together with
the stringed flowers and crystals that
were hanging along though did you wanna
it's like yeah because your crystal
crystal shrine at the house that's a
good energy shield people mean like her
shirt like like it's yeah with what
crystals do for her so okay yeah they're
really powerful energy conduits and oh
yeah I mean where would I not take all
the energy I can get let's talk about
whether the crystals worked or not for
everybody else on the web because here's
the thing
it's a bachelor wedding we know you
probably had some drama there so I'm
gonna rapid-fire with you a little bit
at the wedding who got the most lit
almost Leyland probably one of my best
men right yeah what about who got the
most lit of the bachelor nation crew oh
that's a good question because they
there were more emotional people that
maybe crazy okay anyone got likes
because they also and I think we I think
we saw people who like probably felt
lonely who wanted love they're just kind
of soaking
I was thinking what must it be like to I
mean you had you know the cast at the
wedding
it's
right there in Mexico what must it be
like to attend a wedding with someone
you like just kind of started dating and
are getting really emotional with it
Mike so you guys had a moment where you
weren't sure about the televised wedding
thing
it brought ups you know some
insecurities from the past and so I had
a moment where we thought we weren't
even gonna last together as a couple you
know back in like December and you know
it's one of those things where it's like
an earthquake the plate tectonics like
they're so out of place that
everything's shaking and it was like me
finally dig dug deep and like had these
deep-rooted conversations that allowed
us to like connect and like fully be
stable and like calm again and that
allowed us to go ahead and really
identify the importance of understanding
one another but also being there for one
another as well yeah I mean that really
transcended the relationship it really
was a defining moment because we
realized it wasn't the other people it
was just some deep stuff with it I
appreciate you saying that that you guys
had a moment where you thought I
wouldn't elastic people go through that
and so the key was did you physically
like did you move closer to each other I
don't know where you were living at the
time did you just talk more we were
living in our in our new place yeah I
mean we had already established a
foundation in San Diego but it was one
of those things where you know you're
just you're putting the blame on someone
else you're making excuses and the
problem lived within us
and it took both of us as a team to
realize that we were both having issues
within ourselves that all we needed to
just work on it and come together as one
[Music]